I have to talk about something very
briefly it's unfortunate this doesn't
happen often in our business but we have
tonight accidentally double-booked
comedians for the show and yeah we
booked them both for the same night I am
sorry I don't know how this happened and
I guarantee it will not happen again
it's very unprofessional and you'd think
I'd know better after all these years
and my team would know better but this
happened
so rather than rescheduling one of our
comics this is interesting
they have both graciously agreed to
share their time tonight so please
welcome John doar and Rory Scovel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right yeah look at this crowd boy
you guys think that's a good rule it
with the Z butterfly hate hate piano he
enjoys writing voices I won't flush the
toilet on an airplane because in the
noise I get steersman you go you hit
flush then you turn around nothing
happens for five seconds out of nowhere
I just put a hole in the place I just
put a hole in the frame is Germany it is
like a little heat on you is every
choose you in a question in life there's
a lot of question we all watcher the
same where in the world is Carmen
Sandiego three sixth graders in charge
of the Major Crimes Division
like to do when I'm out on the road arms
expert somebody from the audience Sally
you guys what she's gonna do it she's
gonna put her arms behind me it's called
arms extra fun just have fun with it I
got anal warts we're dancing we're
dancing right now we're doing some
standard like driving in a car maybe now
we're driving well big steering wheel
jeez
[Music]
you'll die
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and really incredible incredible job so
gracious jondura Rory Scovel
that was great out where where can
people catch you guys live oh 14 from
the next night we will take a break we
will be right back thank you very much